und wir sind jetzt live verbunden mit
dem bürgermeister von raki hot air show
er hatte recht die erste frage natürlich
an sie wie geht es ihnen gerade wie ist
die situation momentan in rackith
die situation für angespannt habe ich
den
arbeiten gibt's beschützer aus der luft
die flugzeuge fliegen andauern wir
werden ständig gebombt
zivilbevölkerung könnten
getötet wurde und es schrecklich einfach
der reform ihre stadt wird am heftigsten
angegriffen und das seit tagen wie ist
die humanitäre situation haben sie noch
strom haben sie wasser können sie noch
heizen
es gibt die wasserversorgung in der
ganzen stadt ich kann sagen dass dies
das russische militär zerstört gezielt
unsere infrastruktur
zielgerichtet werden die
verteilerstationen angegriffen hier und
dort
gibt es natürlich störungen in der
stromversorgung
wir können aber auch schatten auf
unseren oder haben heute
alle unsere kommunen kommunale
dienstleistungen sind intakt wir sind
imstande alles schnell
reparieren auch alle leitungen
wasserleitungen kramermahl versuchen
versorgung mit immer wieder nur
gestartete denn es ist da immer noch
sehr kalt und wir wissen dass wir die
stadt gehört liegt ohne wärme versorgen
lassen können
trotzdem ist die situation sehr
schwierig und das ziel gerichtet die in
ihrer struktur angegriffen werde
beständig explosion
gibt und die zivile bevölkerung stieß
erst ein genozid gegen das ukrainische
volk um gegen haken sie sind der
bürgermeister der stadt können sie etwa
einschätzen wie viele menschen befinden
sich momentan noch in der stadt und wie
lange können sie diesen anschlägen
standhalten
die menschen angeht ja ich verstehen
viele berührende und bewohner verlassen
die stadt
gehören der ton fällt gerade wieder
außer in diesem moment noch mal die
frage an unsere übersetzerin das ist
alles live meine damen und herren können
wir den ton noch mal gekommen
ich kann sagen dass
heiko vereint ist und wir werden
durchhalten bis wie siegen hat er auch
aus der nacht sind wieder heftige
angriffe gemeldet worden es wird davon
berichtet dass s21 brennende wohnblöcke
gibt elf von ihnen sollen komplett
zerstört sein gibt es überhaupt angriffe
gegen militärische ziele dort gegen
ziele die die infrastruktur betreffen
oder wird wirklich wahllos auf
zivilisten geschossen werden wirklich
wohnblocks bombardiert und zivilisten
getötet
zivile bevölkerung wird anna gräfin
überzähliger werden angegriffen
vierstöckige häuser werden angegriffen
während heute
sehen wir dass fehler meint schuh flog
der inneren kein ansuchen oder
in der u-bahn wer diese möglichkeit aber
die menschen sterben und es ist
schrecklich
deshalb unterstützen wir heute unseren
präsidenten und
hoffen dass wir durchhalten
der präsident darüber dass sowie und
luftraum über der ukraine schließen
müssen denn
die meisten opfer
kommen zustande weil es so viele
angriffe aus der luft gibt es gibt immer
mal wieder tonprobleme wir bleiben aber
bei hertha hof in diesem moment wie
können sie die stadt überhaupt
verteidigen wie viel ukrainische
soldaten sind im moment in der stadt
ich möchte sagen dass unsere armee ist
wirklich halten harte
rundum hatte daher sind viele menschen
aus vater
eingetragen haben die territoriale
verteidigung sie habe waffen erhalten
und heute mit dem herrn mit den waffen
in händen verteilten sie die stadt